all right great that's just a review so
now I want to get your calculators out
and show you how to use them to do
scientific notation okay so let's have a
look now the reason why I've got both
calculators here I've got my old tiny
one from when I was in year 7 and I've
got the one that I think most of you
have okay and the reason why is there's
a sum difference between the buttons
that I'm going to draw your attention to
in a minute but just to start have a
look at this guy right we did this one
just now okay if I just wanted to type
that you here's the way I would type it
so you go five point two three eight you
see that I should do it on this much in
there five point two three eight okay
you follow it now I need to multiply by
10 to the power 7
so I say times 10 now where's the power
button it looks like it's on up there in
the middle isn't it ok that's that's it
there ok and then I'm popping my 7 okay
so let me repeat that let me delete it
I'll do it just again ok I've got my
significant figures there I say times 10
and then there's my power there
underneath the replay button and there's
my power
now when I say equals does that look
right is it the right number of zeros
yeah yeah good it's on 4 zeros after the
8 perfect just what we expected okay
just for the sake of it let's do the
second one as well and see if we can you
do the negative powers so you got four
point six times ten do the power again
but this time I've got and they give
three at the top now give it to us as a
fraction because it can but how do you
convert from a fraction to a decimal
do you member yeah that's right that
button right there sort of in the middle
so you tap that there you go the decimal
to have the right number of zeros I
think it checks out
yeah that's what we started with let me
go
oh okay what do you wanna what does it
say what is the same four point six
times okay do you have the SD but what
can you press the SD button it doesn't
do anything
it does its now you've got that okay
I'll talk about that in a second I'll
come back to that in a moment
now here's what I want to show you on
the calculator and these are the reason
why I've got both the textbook gives you
a guide of how to use the calculators to
do it faster than this rather than
having to write x turn the power up over
there is a special button on the
calculator for it now your tactics are
bit old they're old enough to bear of
this generation of the calculator right
so the button they talk about is this
one here this exp button okay so you
still got five point two three eight and
then I press E okay exp now the next
theme the next number I put in is going
to be this power up here the seven right
watch what happens if I put the XP 7 and
press the equals that's the number we
got before right so what does that the
XP stand for now your calculators I
think are a little better because you
can see the same button in the same spot
but it's labeled very differently it's
like with times 10 to the power X right
so you can see let's say I'm go to this
calculator and delete that now just
press that button there bottom middle
press it and you've got a little x 10
there right now the next immediate thing
you want to do is press the number that
corresponds to the power which was seven
you press equals oops sorry I didn't
change the number of the front five
point eight three eight there you go
okay so they both give you the same
result if you type it in right
can anyone suggest to me what are some
reasons why this is a better button this
is a better option for us
then going times 10 to the power troops
are times 10 to the power of seven okay
it's easier it's faster isn't it right
um you're also less likely to make an
error if you've been doing um some bunch
of calculations like this
times 10 to the power of 7 and then you
have to yeah
add something in you know 4.6 to the
times 10 to the power of two and you
have a whole bunch of them right the
more you do the more likely I ought to
you know forget you know you might
strike a of one but forget to strike the
zero and then your times one squared and
then that doesn't give you the same
answer right another thing that you
might do by accident I've done this and
I think some other people did this on
Wednesday is you say okay to the power
of seven and then you start writing the
next number you say plus four point six
times ten to the power off now can you
see what I've done wrong what's what's
gone wrong what's gonna be the problem
here yeah it's all in that power this
number is gonna be enormous right in
fact I think it'd be so enormous that if
I press because it's too enormous for
the calculator can't handle it too many
too many numbers okay so having this
kind of doing it the long way
it's slow and you might do it wrong it's
very easy so that's why they give you
this button this arm this shortcut
button down here so you can just go like
that okay yep question is um fix it okay
now it depends exactly what the problem
is now if I it for instance if I put a
bigger number in here suppose I put in
15 now this is interesting have a look I
think this is something like what your
calculator is doing right now it doesn't
have all the zeros it doesn't have a
number in non scientific notation in
fact it's just giving it back to us in
scientific notation
why is done that can you think
it could be a settings thing sometimes
it is that like you're on the wrong mode
or something like that
here's how I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
write out 5.2 3 3 8 times 10 to the 15
it would look like this yeah 15 videos 5
2 3 8 0 0 0 0 it's gonna have 8 more
zeros 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 that is 5 point 2
3 8 times 10 to the 15th now can you see
why the calculator doesn't want to write
it it just doesn't have enough space
like there aren't enough characters here
for it actually too long to put that
number on so that's why I just hands it
back to you in scientific notation
because it's shorter okay but using that
button that um times 10 to the X button
that's what I'd like you to practice in
the last exercise of this number skills
chapter okay